hello first of all I'm going to read a
statement on behalf of Ellie's family
there was no one as beautiful as our
Ellie May
her looks her laugh and the way she
would light up a room as she walked in
she had this way about her that as soon
as he met her he instantly fell in love
with her
everyone that knew
and met El knew how special she was
her laugh was infectious anyone who was
a was around her had a good time
she looked life and had so many amazing
plans for the future she was only just
getting started
Christmas and our family will never be
the same again without her
she was the glue that held this big
family together
we will love and miss her forever
or Ellie May the most beautiful and
bright star out there forever and always
my beautiful Ellie Marlene is the love
of my life and she is my world my best
friend
she will always shine and be beautiful
and bright my Ellie has never gone
Ellie's family are understandably
devastated by her shocking and needless
death
they need answers
and now it's more important than ever
people come forward and tell us what
they know
while I understand how worrying
incidents such as this are I want to
reassure people that my investigation
team is working Round the Clock to get
Justice for Ellie and her family
I can confirm that two people arrested
in connection with Ellie's murder have
been released from custody a 30 year old
male from Tranmere has been recalled to
prison unlicensed and a 19 year old
woman from Rock Ferry has been bailed
it's a 31 year old male still in custody
we've already spoken to a large number
of witnesses and reviewed a vast amount
of CCTV footage and we are pursuing a
number of lines of inquiry still
we are committed to finding the persons
responsible for Ellie Ellie's death and
putting them behind bars
these people don't deserve to be walking
our streets they don't deserve to be
protected they belong in prison
guns have no place on the streets of
merseyside and we're dedicated to
getting weapons off the streets
silence is never an option
we need people to take a stand against
criminals
we need you to speak to us so that we
can take action
let us know who is carrying and storing
weapons and let us do the rest
we know that the answers to this lie
within our communities so my appeal to
you is please tell us what you know and
help us get Justice for Ellie's family
particularly we want information about
the whereabouts of a dark colored
Mercedes that was in the lighthouse
public house
um car park before the incident we want
to know where it came from and where
it's gone since then
information but you don't want to speak
to a police officer directly please
contact us via Crime Stoppers
thank you
talking